[Music]
all right now a warm-up comedian for the
night sorry I'm so late
ladies my name is Danny yeah yeah yeah
that's why all right now I'm gonna get
you guys all warmed up in here how are
you I get you warmed up by playing
little game that I call the yeah yeah
game and here's how you played every
time I say the word yeah you guys say
the word yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
now you guys are ready to play the game
[Applause]
every time I say the word yeah I want
you guys to say yeah yeah no but I say
yeah you go yeah yeah
well alright now when I say the word
yeah what just this section of the crowd
to say oh come on we get it already yeah
[Applause]
all right all right when I say the word
yeah
you sir are gonna wait for three seconds
of silence and then you're gonna say now
when I say the word yeah
you're gonna say oh come on don't be a
jerk and then you're gonna say man this
guy's classic now when I say yeah you're
gonna say why do you always have to be
so sarcastic and then you're gonna say
why I was trying to ruin my fun
and then you're gonna stand up and
you're gonna say that's it I'm not
coming anymore
[Laughter]
[Music]
now say the word yet apparently
something there's trouble in paradise
because when I say the word get you're
gonna say fun leave be at see that one
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright good I like this gentleman right
here now when I see it work yeah you sir
you're gonna stand up and you're gonna
say you talk to her that way one more
time goon squad I will kick your ass
[Laughter]
now when I say the word yeah you're
gonna say Derek
and then Derek you're gonna say cheeks
and you're gonna say you're gonna say
that's my ex-boyfriend international man
of adventure Derek wildstar you remember
that guy you caught me googling those 14
times and then you sir are going to say
Derek wildstar give me a break that's
the name of that character from that old
Japanese cartoon Star Blazers and then
the whole crowd is gonna say shut up
nerd
yeah that's right with the lateral Lisp
awesome now when I say the word Janna
Derek you're gonna say I've come to take
you back boob cheeks but I'm boutiques
you're gonna say we're gonna say but
Derek I thought you were still in South
America and then Derek some reason
you're going to start to a nacho Marx
impression then you're gonna say I was
but they made me leave my place to go
when you do that that's not funny at all
I don't know why you would do that but
for some reason it makes you laugh like
crazy because apparently is an inside
joke from your previous relations and
then you're gonna go uh-oh
Derek you can always make me laugh
laughing come laughing OH
[Applause]
ingeras you're gonna say come away with
me afford my porno copter cuties it's
powered by sex so we'll have to keep all
the way across the Pacific Ocean until
we reach my Fiji fortress that's gained
entirely a cache that's when you're
gonna say that's what you're gonna sleep
that is it I've had enough of your
larger-than-life ex-boyfriends my band
is gonna make it I'm a good bass player
I play bass good yeah awesome Oh
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]